you know here on the channel I cover the
entire Zelda franchise as a whole but
whenever I'm researching for a theory
video about breadth of the wild I'm
constantly reminded about just how much
content there is and how many little
Easter eggs and weird oddities that were
packed into this game even without the
DLC editions it's no wonder it was
delayed for a whole year
I mean a whole two years in DC it's
because of this immense amount of just
good old detail that here we are three
years after its release talking about
the aliens of breadth of the white oh
yeah you heard me
all around us while we were adventuring
across the fields of Hyrule or atop the
peaks of Death Mountain or even through
the jungles of firaon the aliens from
outer space were lumbering around
alongside us allow me to expound upon
what exactly I'm on about here I'm
talking about those giant stone guys the
stone Tallis's now I have pretty good
reason to believe that these dudes are
aliens from off-planet and I have some
evidence and points of logic to back up
these claims that we're gonna get into
in this video but right before getting
into the meat of this juicy theory why
not defeat the YouTube algorithm and
stick around by subscribing to the
channel and drop a like on this video if
you happen to enjoy my little alien
theory but now let us delve into the
mystery of the aliens of Hyrule
so first things first I've got to be
honest with you I had some help with
this theory in the past several months
I've had a few commenters here and there
comment on the mysterious landmark known
as the geese at crater wondering if I
would ever cover the strange area the
most recent comment being this one right
here and while normally my theories pop
in my head as a byproduct of my mind
slowly slipping into madness this time I
decided to take some advice and check
out the crater and boy was i impressed
by what I found for those of you who are
like me and didn't know where the geese
at crater is off the top of my head it's
a relatively small area located to the
west of the tip and the tower clearly
visible from the tower itself scouting
the area you can find several you know
craters that are smaller in size
surrounding a rather large one as if
this wasn't already obvious at this
point the fact that craters pepper the
ground in this area imply some sort of
series of massive impacts made by very
hard objects striking the surface of the
earth at immensely high velocities but
will expand on that in just a bit inside
most of the craters we can actually see
what made those gigantic impacts their
rocks as expected but not just any rocks
living rocks to be specific the smaller
craters have stone peb lights inside
them and the large crater has a straight
up stone talus housed right smack in the
dead center of the impact implying that
it was the once airborne flying object
that struck this piece of the earth and
created this crater now even though this
is the only area in the land of hyrule
that features these strange craters
there is still a heck of a lot of
information that we can read into and
facts that we can logically deduce from
what we've just seen in this game and
previous zelda games so let's talk about
it in the first place the idea of the
stone Tallis's being aliens isn't even
that crazy of a notion because aliens
existing in zelda games is really
nothing new at all the most iconic
appearance of aliens from outer space in
this franchise will probably come to
mind immediately for the more savvy of
you
their who have played the beloved
majora's mask in the game as a sidequest
helping out a little redheaded farm girl
named Romani of course not to be
confused for the alternate universe
equivalent redheaded farm girl named
Malin or even the other redheaded girl
named Maren and the Zelda developers
really liked this character anyway
Romani has a little side quest that
Lincoln helped out with that entails
defending her farm against them which is
the only name Romani refers to these
strange monsters that appear at night as
the Hyrule encyclopedia refers to them
as ghosts but I'm not sure that's a very
accurate name what would the monsters
arriving in a ball of light that we
could refer to as an unidentified flying
object
also known as a UFO and with them being
designed to resemble the flatwoods
monster which is widely regarded as an
alien for those who are into that sort
of thing and the fact that these
quote-unquote
ghosts will abduct cows and even Romani
herself if link fails to kill them all
abduction being a staple of alien
activity and typical science fiction
it's much much more likely that they are
aliens and not simply ghosts or Poe's
and by the way one of the creepiest
things about them is that when they do
return Romani after having abducted the
poor girl her memories have been wiped
clean and she just stares blankly at
Linc when speaking to him really creepy
stuff but it also proves that this isn't
just some figment of these children's
active imaginations aliens are real in
zelda lore as far as breadth of the wild
is concerned though some of you will be
surprised to hear that aliens were
actually a concept for this game as well
Ana leaked early piece of concept art
prior to the game's release we can see
Linc standing in a grassy field looking
out towards the open sky actually this
guy isn't that open because there's a
giant UFO hovering far above the ground
with quite a few smaller spaceships
flying out from an exit on its underside
Satoru Takizawa the art director for
breath of the wild said that quote some
of our younger designers came up with
very unique suggestions like the idea
that UFOs could invade from space and
abduct cattle crazy right also pretty
familiar given the aliens from Majora's
Mask but while this concept of UFOs and
alien spaceships abducting cattle and
even cattle themselves didn't quite make
it into the final game I don't think
they completely gave up on the idea of
extraterrestrials as a whole and now
that I've laid the groundwork for aliens
in the zelda franchise and even in the
development for this very game let's
talk about the stone talus this strange
living rock enemy is actually living
that sounded better on script but what I
mean by that is those little stone
pebble it's that link can literally just
chuck around and watch explode are
actually young stone Tallis's according
to the in-game information we can gather
from the sheikah slates compendium and
since it calls them young this means
they have a growth cycle similar to any
other living species and the reason that
the little stone pedis can be killed so
easily as opposed to their mature
relatives is that they being young have
not hardened their outer layer to the
point to being essentially impenetrable
like the full-grown stone Tallis's which
is our first clue to their alien origins
the fact that the stone talus enemies
have to mature into functionally and
visually resembling rocks but used to be
I don't know softer means that their
skin if you would is actually not made
of rock but made of some unknown
material that resembles rock but grows
over time and also blows up either on
command or when they die so I believe
that it's pretty clear that while these
living stones might be able to reach
into the earth and command rocks that
they use as arms and legs and flying
death balls they themselves are not
actually rock I'm also thoroughly
convinced that stone Tallis's are not a
part of calamity Ganon's army because
unlike the more monstery monsters in the
evil army that spend some of their free
time harassing travelers are chasing
down animals to feast on Stoney's tend
to mostly keep to themselves and don't
appear to try to harm the wildlife
around them unless that is linked of
course and they can even be targeted in
combat by guardians implying a
difference or lack of affiliation for
the Stoney's so given that one of these
rock giants is found right in the middle
of a giant crater in the middle of other
smaller craters the last question we
have to ask is how were these craters
made exactly are we 100% certain that
the only way the craters were created is
from these stone guys falling from orbit
first I tried to theorize about the
possibility that they were spewed out
from within Death Mountain and came to
life somehow but I don't think that
flying through the air from Death
Mountain peak would create a big enough
impact to cause this much damage to the
earth especially for the tiny little
stone pivots which created the smaller
craters
in my opinion the only way these large
craters formed here is from the big
stone talus & Co falling from outer
space and crash landing on planet Hyrule
and since they're alive that can only
mean one thing
aliens so there you have it actually one
more thing I'll cover is since the
Stoney's are present all over Hyrule why
aren't their craters all over Hyrule if
the stone talus is truly came from outer
space how else would they have gotten
dispersed across the land well allow me
to direct the attention to one little
bitty concept that will nicely wrap this
theory up with a neat little bow on top
I mentioned earlier that pebble 'its
grow up to be stone Tallis's right as in
they're essentially babies right well
can't there be more babies made actually
there are some stone telus bosses that
seem to confirm this possibility look at
these two unique ones in particular one
is called stone talus senior and the
other is called stone talus junior
senior and junior the only thing this
implies is a parent and child familial
relation if it was simply referring to
size it would instead be major and minor
and if it was only referring to the age
of the monsters it would be something
like ancient and young but instead they
chose to say senior and junior to be
honest I think they dispersed in the
simplest way possible by multiplying
across the lands potentially over the
course of the past hundred years or
whenever the first ones crash-landed on
Planet Hyrule and that is my theory
about the invading alien species of
breath of the wild and although it was a
lot of speculation what do you think our
stone tell us is actually aliens or have
I fallen a bit too far down the rabbit
hole let me know in a comment below hey
guys thank you so much for watching as
always huge huge huge thanks to my
supporters of which I have a couple new
names to announce
please welcome Brittany M and jerm enjoy
your new benefits guys and if you
watching are interested in getting your
name up here at the end of each of my
videos and some fan
fabulous perks click that join button
below or follow the links in my
description to find out how also down in
that description area are links to my
social media pages like for instance my
discord server so come on over and chat
it up with the most exquisite of Zelda
fans and yours truly that's all I've got
for this one so check out another theory
of mine if you enjoyed this one have a
great rest of your day and also happy
4th of July my fellow Americans this is
Masum Tendo bandit signing out
[Music]